let me say a quick thank you to today's
new member of the day Zachary parem we
are now over 350 three five zero new
members in January this is already the
second best month ever okay ever for new
members and it's only the what day is it
the 16th of the month so we are
potentially on track for the best month
ever for new members Zachary parem is
part of that Gabe cember has been a
member for almost five years and he's
today's sustaining longtime member of
the day thank you thanks a curry thanks
Gabe you can join them at WWJ pakman.com
if the normal membership rates strike
you as a stretch to your budget that's
okay you can use the coupon code this is
20/20
this is to zero to zero because it is
we're already in the 2020 election
that'll save you 40% okay that gives you
a year membership for 36 bucks it gives
you a monthly membership for just three
dollars and 60 cents a month doesn't
sound like much but it moves the needle
if enough people do it let's get into
hey tree at mail if you have never heard
or seen Patriot mail before it is when a
professional voice-over artist's artist
interprets the hate mail that I receive
quick reminder the right of the people
to keep and bear hates shall not be
infringed Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America
because freedom okay so the hatred mail
is starting to get into sort of
election-related I guess you would say
and Bernie Sanders is a topic in today's
hatred mail let's take a listen to it
Pakman has drunk the Bernie bro kool-aid
he is a bias fake asked bottom-feeder
Pakman strikes again lib turd morons
please wake the hell up
Trump 2020 David Pakman lies pretty much
every minute of every show and he does
it with a straight face takes one to
know one I guess it's so weird on the
Bernie stuff because on this program we
this is certainly not a Bernie bro
program in fact I would almost say it's
the opposite except for the fact that I
supported Bernie in the 2016 Democratic
primary but I was out there front and
center saying okay I like many of you in
our audience supported Bernie Sanders in
the primary he lost I think he got the
short end of the stick I think the DNC
screwed Bernie but it's almost November
2016 we now have a choice between Trump
and Hillary and I don't think staying
home is a good idea and I don't think
voting for Trump is a good idea and I
don't think voting third party at this
point is a good idea so I think I don't
know where this person is getting the
idea Pat that this is a Bernie bro
program but the Bernie bros don't like
this program not even I'm not entirely
sure that would even be an insult to and
just the idea that you're lying pretty
much every minute of every show couldn't
the hate reott provide at least one
example I mean I'm sure he would just
come up with some fact that he found
inconvenient it wouldn't be an actual
lie but please support your poor you
claim a little bit well you can use the
coupon code hey tree at 42 save 40% off
of the membership of your choice hey
tree 'it's hate it when david pakman
show viewers and listeners use the
coupon code hey tree at 40 to get
memberships more than three hundred and
fifty new members already signed up in
January if we keep on this pace this
will be the best month ever for david
pakman show membership and you can go to
WWE at minute
come type in hey tree at 40 after you
pick your membership h80 our IOT 4-0 and
you'll say 40 percent and 722 hey tree
'it's will cry every time that coupon
code is used it's a beautiful thing